il a fallu jongler avec la météo
attendre le petit rayon de soleil pour
sortir cette machine des années 30 une
moissonneuse lieuse lalieux elle fauche
le blé tendre sur des tapis
ça montre ça monte dans des tapis
roulants et ça vient ici avec un noir
qui étaient les premiers ne qui a été
fait dans les années 40
et après ça fait une gerbe de blé la
cause de la pluie les ajustements
étaient nécessaires c'était aussi le cas
pour faire fonctionner notre machine
pourtant on va déplacer là bien la
moissonneuse batteuse du fil à retordre
on a déjà des problèmes d'humidité de
trucs et puis on est
on a perdu un petit peu les habitudes
donc j'attends conforme tout le monde
qu'on voit là c'est pour ça qu'on est un
petit peu on a perdu un petit peu de
temps mais normalement ça va marcher
après quelques tentatives ce sera
effectivement le cas
comme il ya 60 ans en récolter le blé
l'été et la batteuse année l'hiver dans
toutes les fermes il déplacé un jour
deux jours ça dépend donc on était les
battles et d'ouvriers il était dans la
poussière dans la grange y avait
beaucoup de poussière à la ferme du
grand carouge
il y a une cinquantaine de vieux
tracteurs tous en état de marche
ils sont réparés dans cet atelier s'est
beaucoup des problèmes d'injection des
problèmes d'embrayage des problèmes de
motorisation des moteurs grippé on re
des grippes les moteurs on est plusieurs
mécano et 11 et brouillent voilà c'est
bien mais ils ont beau fonctionner ces
outils restent moins performants que les
machines plus récente une machine comme
celle ci n'était capable de récolter
peut-être quatre hectares de blé dans la
journée il y a
60 ans et aujourd'hui
une machine
des travaille de la même manière il fait
ça à l'heure depuis plus de dix ans
l'association du grand coeur rouge
organise cette fête des moissons qui
rime avec transmission